another example is kingship you start
reading from 1st Samuel chapter 8
on the people of Israel told Samuel we
want a human King we want a human King
and Samuel says why why do you want a
human
King don't you want God to be your king
no we want a human King 1 Samuel
8 here it is just read entire chapter I
can't read all of it they came and they
look all the nations have human Kings
all the nations have human Kings we want
a human King and then Samuel says why
why do you want a human King don't you
want God be your king he will be your
king from heaven and he'll raise up
judges to lead you no no no no we want
to be like the Nations and then Samuel's
heart was broken but watch What God Says
NOW Watch God's heart break come on in
Kitty you want to come in coming in no
all right stay out all right Watch God's
heart
break look what he says you see how long
it takes me to unack these truths look
what it says then all the Elders of
Israel gathered together and came to
Samuel and they said to him behold you
have grown old and your sons do not walk
in your ways your sons are corrupt now
appoint a king for us to judge us like
all the nations but the thing was evil
in the side of Samuel when they said
give us a king to judge us now watch
What God Says and Samuel prayed to now
look when you understand the true God as
he is revealed in scripture in Jesus
you'll actually believe it or not
shockingly you'll start feeling sorry
for God I'm not lying you're GNA
actually get heartbroken for God you're
going to start feeling sorry for him
look what he says then Yahweh said to
Samuel listen to the voice of the people
in regard to all that they say to you
for they have not rejected you but they
have rejected me from being King over
them you can sense God's heartache right
there
Samuel they're not rejecting you they're
rejecting me they don't want me as king
that's words from a heartbroken God you
see
it you see what he
said see when you understand the
scriptures you're going to actually be
heartbroken for what we do to
him you will be
heartbroken for the pain we're causing
him you see that
words it's okay Samuel I know you're
hurt for me but it's not you they reject
it they reject me my people don't want
me they don't want
me they don't want me right doesn't that
hurt your heart right doesn't that hurt
your heart
I'm gonna have to sit on the couch guys
because sometimes I need my back because
that's a hard chair I got to get a
better chair maybe this week God
willing you see
it so what do we
learn what do we learn and someone
captured
it even the Kings of Israel was
something God did not
want so God gives them what they want
even though it breaks his heart but now
you see how beautiful God is let me show
you how beautiful God
is look let me finish it for they have
not rejected you but they have rejected
me now right there if you could hear God
speak audibly he would be saying it in
pain his heart being
crushed like all the Deeds which they
have done since the day that I brought
them out of from Egypt even to this day
and that they have forsaken me and
served other gods so they are doing to
you also so so now listen to their voice
go
ahead give them what they want they
don't want me as king fine however you
shall somly testify to them and tell
them of the custom of the king who will
reign over
them go
ahead
yeah yeah get this guy out of here you
see the
pain but now you want to
see the heart of God then he gives them
the best of both
worlds you want a human King all right
I'll give you one but I'm going to do
you one better I will become
human I will become man I will become
the physical son of David so you can
have a human King ruling over you who is
still your God hence Jesus the God
man you see see the beauty of
God you want a human King all
right so I'm going to give you what you
want but I'm going to do you one better
I will become a physical son of David I
will become a human descendant David so
you can have an Israelite ruling over
you who's still your God I jesus the God
man that's what he did in
Jesus yep exactly Greg that's what he
did that's what he
did you see it
so he says all right I'll give
you I'll give you a human King but it's
going to be me I God become a human by
Nature a physical Descent of David so
you have the best of both worlds God in
flesh the God man ruling over
you yeah thank
you I wonder if you're J okay what do we
learn here
what do we learn here we learned if
you're paying
attention not everything that God
allowed or legislated he approved of not
everything written reflects God's heart
and not every statement written is from
God's perspective you see how sensitive
it is when you're dealing with the Bible
you have to learn how to interpret the
Bible how not to interpret the Bible you
see why it keep saying now everyone
should teach and I'm not trying to be
arrogant I wasn't looking to be a
teacher the spirit put me in that
situation and may perfect me to know the
depth of scripture you understand now
did you learn now now this gives you a
much deeper richer understanding now you
can say wait maybe this is not God's
perspective just because it's
written yep you got it Greg you're
getting it brother